Welcome everybody to the session new insights into AV trafficking we have
in the session and just as a reminder do not use flash photography in the
session probably distracting and I don't think I need to remind everybody
anybody about the Wi-Fi anymore at this point so let's just go straight ahead to
the first speaker which is Sloan Wan from UMass Chan Medical School good afternoon
everyone my name is Sloan Wan I'm reporting our study on behalf of Dr.
Tsoit Mongtian Tsoi unfortunately she can't make to the meeting today so I
presenting on behalf of her on our study advancing capsidic engineering and
the transcriptional regulation towards decoding the role of a V1U so the
ocular gene therapy is at the forefront of the gene therapy especially since the
first AV gene therapy product like sterna get approval from FDA and then the
majority of the ocular gene therapy is conducted through the separation injection
but with a number of limitations such as limited therapeutic efficacy and then
the complexity of the rational surgery as alternative intravitory injection
theoretically can divert more of our vectors